okay welcome back everybody our next
speaker is Felix move you're already
Matt in the panel he will talk about
from the life for data scientists thank
you so I have the pleasure to continue
with this cutter with the discussion of
the pedal and this time alone so this is
good so there will be no other opinions
no I'm joking so it will be a quite long
and long talk with touching quite a few
different topics so just ask in between
is best because afterwards might be too
you might not remember everything so
short outline of what I'm going to talk
about so in the beginning I will
introduce a few passwords which all of
New of you already know of course but
still to see how I would define them and
then most of the talk will be about a
definition of a trial of a definition
what data science could be or at least
how it is for me when I work as a data
scientist and then in the end of you
short real-world examples where we did
customer projects involving data science
to give you kind of an imagination how
it works out there ok so I begin with
this famous hype cycle of gardna so
which probably all of you already know
so the scientists maybe not but so you
probably cannot read what is written
there but basically what it means is
that each year Gardner publishes a list
of these passwords which are just hip at
that at that time and estimates at the
time how long it takes until they become
stand out and then that means that they
are actually used with some let's say
business value out there and what you
see on the on the right side of the of
the blood so the small blood so this is
just how it usually behaves such such a
hype cycle so there's a there's a
technology trigger in the beginning and
then such a password is really hyped and
it goes up to this to this peak and then
usually it falls down into
the trough of disillusionment and then
afterwards it goes up to until it's
really in in production and you can use
it predicted productively and here you
see the oops me here you can see the
some words which which are interesting
for for our topic so this means data
science and prescriptive analytics here
so I will go through those in the end of
things you already had in the panel
discussion which is just a chat hype at
the moment and big data which is already
on the way down to to the trough of
disillusionment so when here's a
comparison between the last two years so
you see the blue cycles there's a big
data so which was just under peak and
it's now going down as and the time for
it is relatively long so it's five to
ten years and what is the what is the N
red is the is the time for predictive
analytics so predictive analytics went
through electively quickly so it's only
two years so that means um actually this
was something which was better defined
than ten big data so you can really say
what the predictive analytics is with
big data it's much more difficult to
define what you actually mean with it so
what I will start with that try to look
if at least an explanation what it means
for me and basically it's just the data
which comes from all the different kind
of industries and economy so there might
be something from Stock Exchange which
you can use to to try to give some
forecasts there which is usually pretty
difficult but you could earn a lot of
money with it of course then we heard
about banking and insurance which is
difficult because of data security in in
Europe retail which I said in the in the
discussion already is something which we
have done a lot in the past so there you
can do current like a replenishment and
demand forecasts dynamic pricing and so
on which is also true for online shops
location-based services might be
something which could be interesting in
the future so you saw yesterday to
interesting talk about the cost so this
was something which you see there are
some applications of it
and then of course production an
industry which already mentioned which
will be in future maybe one of the of
the biggest things to come with the
Internet of Things and with really the
possibility to store and process this
whole large data set which are there so
then predictive analytics which I said
which is something which is more quite a
bit easier to define so actually what is
written the artist that analytics are no
longer a nice to have so what I mean
with that is basically in the past what
was there is this descriptive analytics
so this is there for tens of years so um
this is basically business business
intelligence so that means drill down
stuff you can see what happens you can
maybe get an idea what you could do but
there's no real action from it dano
forecasts yeah if you really go to it
why did it happen so you get an idea
about your business then your call would
call it more like diagnostic analytics
maybe and then if you go to of just from
this information to do an actual
forecast then you would come to this to
this terms predictive and prescriptive
analytics so predictive analytics is
basically what you would define as as
machine learning so that you do actually
forecasts with for some target variable
and then but we would trust these
forecasts the customers usually cannot
do too much so they would need people on
their side which can get some value out
of it so that means usually what is
better if you already deliver decisions
to the customer and this would mean
prescriptive analytics so you are right
at how can we make it happen so this
just means you give the customer already
his business case at hand and not just
numbers which will have no use maybe in
the end so this is basically what you
would like to have so you have
uncustomary maybe your controller and
then the data is delivered from the
customer so here is now in the cloud so
this would mean so our model more or
less is that we that we do it as
in our own platform so the customers to
deliver us the data why are defined API
and then we run all the stuff on our
side and deliver decisions and actions
back so another model would be what we
also heard yesterday most of the
customers maybe would like to have it on
premise more so in industry or banking
or such things so this is usually the
case so then you can maybe just leave
out the cloud and see it as a as a
service on there this works exactly the
same way so you have a defined data
delivery then you have your predictive
application and send the decisions and
actions back and then there might be a
controller which decides what to do with
the decisions or you have it completely
automated which might be the way to go
in future and of course you can also use
external factors which are not in the
data delivered by the customer so this
might be something like weather data
economic indices or whatever so and this
is of course something which is then the
which has to be done in the prolific
application that you trust include all
these different data informations and
build a model out of it so then I come
to the to the to the central term data
signs so this is now something which we
had already that is quite difficult to
define and so I would say all the stuff
which we discussed there is that one set
that it's basically trust model
development so that data scientists
dealing with statistics dealing with
machine learning and another one said
it's all about engineering so and
actually poses true I would say so a
data scientist has to do all these
things so it is it is all about
engineering that's true so there is no
data scientists which who cannot has no
coding skills I would say so this this
will not work so a data scientist is
basically a software engineer but it's
also necessary that you have some
background in statistics and machine
learning that really understand the
stuff so that means this predictive
modeling and machine learning and
statistics what I said there of course
it is also coming to statistics i will
explain it a bit and also data
exploration means you have to know what
you are doing you have and you have to
have the skills to to really explore the
data that means in pious and you have to
know that the libraries you have to have
the ability to code and what what comes
then there additionally is the business
development and data storytelling part
so that means that usually also have to
deal with the customer so there might be
some data scientists which are only may
be doing the development inside the
larger company and have their own
project manager somebody who does this
stuff but usually I would say the data
scientist should be able to to tell the
outcome also also to the customer and
also develop a kind of a business case
so this also belongs to the do the
duties of the data scientist and a large
point which is there just on the left
side which you cannot read that good I
guess so this is then also a bit about
operations so um data science in that
sense that it makes a business value
means that you're not building just a
model and then as we heard yesterday it
goes to powerpoint to die so but it
means that you have you have a model
which is actually running productively
in the end and which is which is then
used and you have to to find a way to to
define the infrastructure to have the
data access working with a solution for
storage and so on and so on so all this
belongs also the duty so you have to
know a lot of things actually and a lot
of topics to cover and this is basically
what a data scientist do so i will now
give a few humor details through some of
these points and i will mostly
concentrate on the on the machine
learning and statistic point because
there might also be some people out
there which are not from signs for the
others at my tip it may be boring but
anyway so basically a what what is what
has to be son to be said why do we do it
with webster
so and this is because there are two
extremes and this the one is there's
complete randomness so this might be
something like lottery so where you
cannot say anything so one would say
that Minister chaos or something like
that and the other thing would be you
can just calculate everything that's
just causal effects and you know the
outcome like in mechanics or for a
pendulum or something but the reality in
business is usually something in between
so you have you have a part which is
actually non-random which you can
calculate which might be something like
expertise knowledge or domain knowledge
or something and you usually have to
extract this and Exploited so you should
not include that stuff in your model so
you have just have to know your your I
your use case have to extract this thing
and then exploit correlated pattern in
the data trust by your machine learning
model so by our statistical models and
this is basically what you should do so
coming shortly to statistics so what's
the probability for head or tail in in
such an experiment usually for a
frequent istic approach you would just
have to try it very often and then you
need a lot of experiments and then you
can decide what the probability is so um
but this is not reality usually so there
you have only one trial or you don't
know in beforehand what it will be so
you need kind of a different answer to
to solve such things and what you could
do is for example based in statistics so
this is there you have you have a prior
knowledge which I have notated there
with under on the right hand side so and
this basically includes the information
you have before so I will come to it in
more detail then you have this
likelihood which is basically what you
optimize so this is what what you would
use in your which would minimize in your
likelihood method or whatever so and
then in the end you are you are
interested under prediction so that
means the the hypothesis under the
condition of the data which actually
have and the data in the denominator is
trust for normalization
so this isn't changing in the process so
and by this so what is interesting that
is the prior so and the question is
where to get the prior from and this can
then be a for example historic data so
that you you know something from your
business beforehand which you could use
some statistics or something um it can
be some properties after of the systems
of our foreign experiment it would be
just that you know that your that both
sides of your coin are equal it can be
it can be experienced or what I already
said expert other main knowledge so this
is mostly very interesting and you can
just include it in your model by this by
this mythology of patients that he
sticks um and just a remark there if you
know nothing about it then if you know
for other information is there then what
you often take is a uniform prior which
is actually not the best thing to do so
actually Lotus hello digits are more
frequent than hi digits and this is what
you see there so this is just a
statistic effect so just good to know so
this is something basically everything I
would like to say a 22 basic statistics
so but what is nice to know additionally
is a correlation versus causality so
this is something which was discussed in
the past quite a few time and you see
there a paper where it was mentioned
that basically causality is that so
actually scientists know that that you
should not draw the collusion a
conclusion simply on the basis of
correlation because you are you have to
extract the causal effects beforehand
but one could think that if you have
really big data you could do everything
with correlations but actually this is
not completely true so it's not always
sufficient so it might be okay in most
use cases that you just go without
anything to your problem just put it
into a machine learning model and think
that everything works out but in reality
there are actually many use cases where
you have to maybe do some decisions
which
which are then changing the behavior of
your model so that means that in this
case x and y are can be trust correlated
but there can also be some causal
influence from one side on the other so
they are on the right hand side so X
causally influence why but not the other
direction and this can be an interesting
information for a model so for example a
relevant for business cases would be for
example dynamic pricing so if you have
an online shop and you can decide what
the price of an item should be and what
you want to optimize is the revenue in
the end so that means your target would
be the revenue you have some historic
data which are all your features you
have from from your shop and you have an
action which you can do so that means
you can change the price and by changing
your price you're actually changing your
model in the end so you're behaving
those you are changing the whole
behavior of the system so and for that
you cannot just say that the causal
effects have no influence and you can
actually exploit that fact so for
example if you sink on promotions for
example catalogue sending so that means
you would have would have a customer
which sends out all censored catalogs
and then hopes that the revenue for the
customers who get a catalog is is
increased and for that it's very
important to really take into account
the politics in the past for example so
which customers got the catalog in the
past is it better to send them to send
somebody a catalog or not so maybe
somebody is spending money anyway then
you shouldn't waste money on your
marketing stuff maybe it's there are few
customers which haven't spent much in
the past but should get the catalog and
then would but they would buy something
and for that you could you could use
such an effect inside your machine
learning model and could trust exploit
this so this and this is then really
going into the direction of
reinforcement learning also and this can
be an interesting topic and actually we
have done quite a few projects doing
that stuff
so then to the next point very shortly
data exploration so we had already quite
a bit about it and everybody said okay
most of data science is just about
transferring the data doing your
pre-processing knowing the features dive
into data visualize them and so on and
this is actually true so most of the
work is it's really done there so in
your models most of the data scientists
are not really developing let's say
machine learning models like an advanced
support vector machine or something so
they are actually working with the data
so what you need to have is you have you
need to have some some good models which
are working for you to understand what
correlations are in the data and to
understand what happens to it how they
are correlated to each other what would
be interesting what is the correlation
to the target and so on this means you
usually should do also such
two-dimensional distributions you should
check how the different variables behave
you can do this with profile blood heat
maps or whatever so one example would be
would be something like this so here are
under under to access our trust your
features so the same on those X's and
you see always the profile blood of one
feature versus the other and then the
diagonal you would see the profile blood
to the target and by doing something
like that you can learn something about
your data set and also you can you
should do some pre-processing before you
send it to your machine learning model
so because um if you have information
but what you can give the model then
it's always better than to try trust
model to learn everything because to
have your own brain inside the thing is
is usually much better than to just
leave it to the model and yeah few
things which I which I mentioned with
which would need for optimized
approaches so you could think of you
have discrete features and you have
continuous features maybe in your data
set and you would handle them of course
a probe separately so maybe you want to
have some some regularization on them
before you before you send them to a
method then what you
would do for example for discrete
features might be something like I don't
know a better binomial regularization
and for continuous features you might
use splines orthogonal polynomials or
something like that and you have to find
a way to distinguish maybe missing
missing values which we have in your
data you can sometimes you come and
exploit them sometimes they are just
disturbing your message but they can
contain information of course and you
might want to have a measure of the
statistical significance of your input
variables so maybe you want to leave
some out to do not disturb in your
message in the end this can be so this
is really important and one should
always think about it if if one is
developing a new method so but then
coming to the core so to machine
learning so this is something which
basically everybody of new probably
knows so machine learning just
approaches machine learning approaches
just extract the patterns from the data
so that means you have your historic
data or in physics it might be monte
carlo simulations of your exposé own or
something like that and out of this you
are you want to learn how a typically
exposure looks like and then you want to
exploit it an unknown data set and in
business for the future for example you
learn from the historic data and exploit
it in the future and basically there are
you can distinguish it into
classification and regression so um a
classification would be trust to put it
to to put a specific sample to a
category so it might be yes or no it
might be one or zero and it might be a
ten categories or something like that
and in the end you want to give a
probability if in if it's in zero are in
category one for example and why a
probability so you could also just give
just give a label in which it is but
usually with probability you get also
measure and now probabilities and you
might also use it in another advanced
method to maybe build a regression out
of it so
to build a regression model out of out
of many classifiers for example if you
if you really do it with a probability
output and then combine it in a basin
way then you have an easy way to build a
regression model out of classifiers
which are usually much easier so
regression model is just a prediction of
a quantity so that means for example
there might be a the sales tomorrow or
insurance claim it could be either with
anything so usually most of the cases
which we are dealing with our more
regression problems but there might be
also some interesting classification
things like for example and probability
something like that I will say I will
give an example in the end of both of
them so and another thing about it is
the training methods so there are
basically two different training methods
so supervised and unsupervised learning
so as I said so you just use historic
data and with the with the features
inside it and have a target defined in
the supervised learning and this target
is known and you want to to build a met
from input to output so from new
features to the target and in the
unsupervised learning so sometimes also
just once as a cluster ring to it so
this means you just want to have to find
the structures in your data and you have
no target defined poses oppose are
useful it depends on the use case if you
do prediction all models most of the
cases I would say I'd supervised
learning what I said before with the
reinforcement learning our stuff might
be something additional so which I've
not written down here again so then what
algorithms one can use um I won't go to
an into detail of any of those so we can
discuss later on if you are interested
but so for example random forest
gradient boosting so these are things
which came up in the last in the last
years let's say which are really good
and very interesting I'm support vector
machines neural networks out there for
years now neural networks are really old
so I've have two pictures they are now
from from
network how it works so they got they
got interesting again only maybe 20
years ago or something 25 years ago when
the soul back propagation stuff was
invented and what you can see there is
how it works you have your input so your
features so which are already pre
processed as i said so this your feet
into a model and then you might have
different layers so here's just one
hidden layer so this is our the green
dots in the middle and it's all coming
to one output in the end and in the in
the bottom plot should see you just see
one of those one of those hidden layers
for exams one of such neurons let's say
what output node it could also be and
how it would work is you just define
some weights which are then which are
then going to some function so might be
a sigma it or something which which you
see there and which is I then combine to
one output so this is basically how this
method works and for the others it's
always the same so you have you have to
have some some multivariate method which
which includes all your your information
with you have in the input and you want
to build it to one output okay so what
is one problem there so maybe the most
important problem you have in machine
learning is the curse of dimensionality
so that means if you have many variables
in your data so then this leads to a
high dimensional feature space so what
you see there is just if you have one
variable two or three and the volume of
of these of this feature space increases
exponentially with the number of
dimensions of features and usually you
have a lot of features in your data and
sometimes it happens that you have only
a few samples so if you think on a time
series or something and a lot of
external information you might have then
you have a lot of a lot of features and
only a few hundred samples and then it's
very difficult to learn to trade a
machine learning model on it so then you
have to find some other ways or some
intelligence to avoid such a situation
so to explain it a bit more easier I
would say you can you can see it here
with with an example where you just have
four points and want to describe them
for example by Apple on
polynomial so um if you have a model
with enough parameters so that means few
samples and a lot of features then you
can just fit it and it works in your
training data set but it it won't work
later on in your prediction data set so
it's better to have a model which is not
that complicated with less parameters
but which is generalizable so for
example um we heard yesterday in this
car talk which was really great but
there we had one example where we had
something which might not have the this
feature of generalization in if so there
we said it was that that one of those
cars is just trained on this unjust this
specific cars on this specific driver so
that means you can only predict this
driver in the end but it what you would
be interested in the end would be of
course something like you train on just
a set of a few different cars and then
exploited to make predictions for all
cars in that city or something like that
so this is what I would mean with
generalization so and this is something
which is sometimes not so easy to have
okay so now I'm a bit more technical I
just choose now a supervisor aggression
for it so how a fit and a predict would
work in such a method so here you have
now your your inputs so this is now for
one sample just a few different things
which you could use so maybe four if you
want to make a prediction for online
shop for the revenue of I don't know a
t-shirt or something like that and then
there might be an article size a picture
size and so on but there might be also
some more difficult features in it so
you could build beforehand the time
series model for example which gives you
the information about the sales in the
past so it might be a simple moving
average but it could also be something
more advanced like a normal model or
whatever and you just can include those
information also to your features or you
can maybe train a random forest
beforehand and then put the output of
the random forest inside another method
so this is something so what you build
out of your features is up to you can be
as complicated as you like and then you
combine it with such and such one
machine learning fit
and extract the significant information
and in the end to trust capture the
model parameters inside an expertise for
example for a neural network this would
be these dissuades of the of the
different sort of different weights
which we saw in the previous slide and
what is interesting here of course so
this is also is only one sample but you
would do a fit of course and many
zombies and for the predict you would
then do it on one sample so that means
that um it it might be a batch
prediction we're just the predictor
whole data set or it might be also some
real time application we're just get
also only one sample at a time and then
you do the prediction on that but what
is interesting is that it's new data so
that means you haven't seen this this
stuff before there was nothing learned
by heart or something so really have to
generalize it before and then you would
use the expertise you have fun you have
drained in before and then to give some
output in the end and um what is what is
the important point is that the output
is not just the number so it should
actually return in case of a
classification set a probability and in
case of the regression it should in best
case give you a probability density
distribution and the reason for that is
there are two things so first of all it
will give you an individual density
distribution so that means as you do it
an example separately you get not let's
say an average sample in the end what
what you would get out there which is
the dark curve but it would be an
individual event so in an individual
density distribution and this is this is
of course interesting because you are
interested in in the real localization
and dispersion measure of this one
sample and not of your whole samples so
you want it individualized and the
second point is you don't want a single
number because you want also an estimate
on how precise this so usually all these
distributions are not symmetric but they
are symmetric so
you think on Justin as i said the sales
of a t-shirt or something so this is
somehow distributed like a plus or
distribution or some things or something
like that so it won't be a garden
usually and that means if you want to
exploit more than just this one number
of the mean of your distribution then if
you have such such a complete PDF then
you can do something like okay I'm not
taking trust the mean of this
distribution but I would take maybe the
median or I would take maybe the ninety
percent percentile so it might be that
you're that you want to be pretty sure
that you are not overestimating or not
under estimating so this just depends on
under costs I will come to that in a few
moments and for that it's it's there's
no other way then just predict the whole
distribution and most of the methods are
not doing this so this is something
which is which is very important so as I
said the cost so these these are
actually the thing which you have to
optimize so you need to have a cost
function mostly from the define from the
cast or maybe if you cannot do it by
itself and what you see here is in the
black would be the actual prediction and
if it would be too low or too high you
would the costs would increase and
usually this goes more or less linearly
in both directions and the best point
estimator for your a prediction what we
trust the minimum of the cost function
of course and because of this linear
cost functions in both on both sides you
also have to think about what would be a
good measure measure for the prediction
quality of your method and the usual
case is the mean squared error so this
is just connected to the mean of your
distribution and this is what what most
estimators just give you and um this is
okay in most use cases but actually if
you think on business cases it's
something not completely completely
perfect because doubling the deviation
does not lead to four times the cost as
we saw under
blood before so there are no quadratic
euros but only linear euros in the end
so and also this is this evaluation
would be dominated by outliers if you
have something which is far out on the x
axis then you see the costs which would
be a very big so what is better is of
course a linear method because if you
have linear cost functions then this
would be the ma de for example and this
would be just more realistic in in most
cases and it's connected to the median
which is a robust estimator and so
usually what you would choose for if you
trust knowing nothing about your message
you would probably choose the media and
instead of the mean and this is also
something which you wouldn't get from
most of the methods if you don't give a
probability density in the end okay
another another point which which I had
under what the data signs scientist is
doing was this business development and
that's most of the cases it's important
that the data scientist is also able to
define a user business case because if
you come to the customer in most cases I
would say the customers don't really
know what they want so they they want
usually some cool big data application
or something like that but in the end
that that it goes productive it took
that it goes to production and that you
can really earn money on a lot longer
scale then you need to have a business
case which is really a maybe saving the
customer some money and for that you
have to understand what is going on in
that business you have to be an expert
and in that in that domain at least a
bit I would say you have to understand
what what processes lead to the
decisions and customer side and have to
see if you if you can actually support
it if there are data available which
could do it if it's possible for the
customer to get the data if the quality
is okay for your for your methods and
you have to define of course what what
target would be good for for a business
case and of course in the end also how
you would evaluate the performance maybe
you build a model you think that it's
very good you send the predictions to
the custom
but you haven't talked about about the
measure on how you would you will decide
in the end if it's successful and then
the customer might come up with the MSC
and you have you think that it's much
more it's much better to take the MiG so
this might be something which will just
have to to decide together with the
customer what you are doing and this
would be something like business skills
I would say so usually a how such a
project would go as you would have an
initiative data exploration so you get
the data from the customer just what
bring it to your maybe platform or
whatever it might be also that you just
get the data as it is from the customer
and you transform it by yourself in a
way that you can use it and then you
look through the data build a very first
very simple model and evaluate the
results so this is this is important
that you not just start with the with
the whole thing built the most most
difficult model and after a few months
you try to to give the first results
back to the customer but better build a
simple model first evaluate the results
bring it to a stage where where it can
really be evaluated and then talk to the
customer to discuss it to see if it
really generates value for them and
after that you can you can have such a
cyclic approach that you improve the
model do maybe more complicated
approaches or whatever yeah and in the
end what is very important so it should
go productive as i said so you should
have should find a way to to opera
operationalize it or whatever so at
least that it runs securely that it runs
maybe for weeks or months or as long as
the customer needs that service so in
this is then also kind of an also in
software engineering aspect to it so you
are not writing scripts which are used
one time but you're writing really
software which is there to last so this
means you need to have some coding
skills at least if you implement the
model and take it to a production
environment so of course you need some
coding skills for data exploration
well but this is I would say a bit
different so and the plots you see there
is coming to two pies and actually so we
are using in our company um mostly pies
now at least four for the machine
learning aspect and you see there in the
upper curve this is actually the the
percentage grows in the last year's of
the different programming languages and
your day you can see that Pisan actually
had quite some grows in the last year's
and just in the very last two years or
something that all dis hold data science
thing when it became it became a
password i would say or that all the
data scientists came up so one saw that
also pison got got much more popular
let's say surprisin is really becoming
the language of choice for the data
scientist is what what one can see and
this was different in the past so there
it was it was mostly are I would say
which was used for for machine learning
stuff at least outside of academia and
I'm usually what you had is this to
language problem so that means that you
had something like our or MATLAB 22 in
to look through your data build your
models and everything and then in the
end if it if you want to bring it to a
production system you needed something
else like C++ or Java or whatever so
that meant that you had to re-implement
it again or maybe have to write
everything from scratch and this of
course is it's expensive it's also
dangerous because it can be your model
can be wrong afterwards so you have to
check it again and so on and so on so
usually it's good to have a language
where you can just do both things at
least almost as good as you could do it
with the with the domain specific things
and something like this is pious so it
has a large body of libraries or create
community you have a cool stuff where
can do machine learning with so for
example scikit-learn you can do also web
applications
to programming you are really fast for
if you do just the model development and
you have you have tools to to get also
performance boost for things where you
really need it so in algorithms usually
okay first you should of course look
that your algorithm is fast so you could
you could have a performance boost by
such a method for a poor algorithm and
it would be just stupid so the first
thing is of course to have a cool
algorithm but afterwards it might be
also useful to have some methods like
sighs no an umpire where you can really
just then increase the the speed of
Tyson a lot because just as it is a
dynamic interpreted language is just not
that fast as CS in four loops or
something like that okay and it has also
straight forward integration of external
compiled libraries which can also be
very useful if you think on numerical
methods or something like that so
something which came up in I would say
the last maybe few years as is really
that you have data sets which are larger
than then your memory so what are the
methods which I showed so neural
networks and support vector machines and
all of those so usually desire these are
algorithms which where all the data
which you want to drain off they need
have to just to fit into memory so you
will have to load all the data on your
machine in memory and then you can run
your method on it so this is can be
difficult if you if you want to drain on
a large data set so of course what you
could do you could trust to a trival
paralyzation let's say that you just
split your data into 100 trunks and then
tree train on those 100 trunks and
predict in the end again and these
undies data trunks for the unknown data
but then you might lose information so
if you think for example on on some rare
event so if you want to let's say
predict some sales in a supermarket and
then
there is a specific behavior before
Christmas for example then you have all
your few events of Christmas in your
data set and if you would split it up
too many you might just suffer from from
the kit from the case that you don't
have the correlations between those
variables and all the others in so in
such situations what you want to do is
you want to drain on all data available
and for that you need some some methods
to to really let's say not have this ram
usage problem and for that you need some
intelligent algorithms which are able to
stream or some out of co algorithms and
in pies and there are a few solutions to
do it so you just have to write your
your cool algorithms which can do this
and then you can use the pies and tools
to to do something like that and the
other problem is of course runtime then
so this wouldn't solve your your runtime
problem you would still be slow but for
that you would need to write parallel
algorithms which you could which I could
then combine in the end so this is maybe
a basically what is stand with MapReduce
or something like that okay and the last
point I had had under under data science
definition was to specialization stuff
and the data storytelling and this is
just important to to let the customer
understand what you are doing so to tell
him a story which which convinces him
that it's that it's useful for him what
you are doing and what you see there is
just in simple example how you could
maybe make something like this more
visible so you have trust a time series
of of the sales of shrimps on the
Italian coast and there's sometimes
there are these peaks in and if you
would just overlay a calendar of it so
you would see okay this is always the
vacation season or something like that
so this means just a simple story you
would have to tell the customer that
they are understand what's going on and
it can be also something like that so
here you just see the the prediction and
the forecasts over later on a time
series space and there you could see ok
so it's
more or less okay but on one specific
day I don't actually know what's going
on and then you could do something like
this so you cannot read it now but it's
not just the different features and how
they would influence the prediction in
the end so that means this is now a
multiplicative model so that means each
of the features gets a factor in the end
which would say okay if the factors ones
and this feature has no influence and
the specific prediction on this sample
and here it would say okay this feature
as a factor of two so this had a large
influence on your on your model this had
the different direction the only effect
of 0 point 25 or something today I could
tell the customer okay for this specific
prediction your disperse you're
influencing display your most important
influencing factors and for that of
course you also need methods which can
do this so you need the algorithm which
is able to do this but this could be
then of course pretty cool to convince a
customer why are ye should use that
stuff because you could say okay if this
is the case then maybe my prediction or
my sales slow so now in the end I don't
know how much time I have but to have a
few um real-world examples which are
promised so try management already said
so it might be something and in
telecommunications or hear this plot is
from a newspaper contract project so
where you want to know the risk for a
specific customer to cancel the contract
why do you want to notice because if you
if you know which customers are risky
then you can have some some activity two
maybe just avoid the canceling of the
contract let's say so and this would be
an example of just the prediction in the
first place so that you say I predict if
a customer is most likely to to cancel
the contract and what you see there is
it's just the the evaluation of such a
prediction so this is a lift chart so
you on this point you would identify
sixty-seven percent of all customers
which are likely to cancel the contract
by just predicting up by just having the
first ten percent so this means you send
you you would do an
action on only ten percent of your of
your customers because you might have
owned earlier let's say marketing budget
to to call ten percent and if you have a
this method then you would have
sixty-seven percent of all the
cancellous inside the first ten percent
so this is of course then good but in
the end the question is is there
something which has really value to the
customer and it might have if the
customer does the right thing that the
right decision out of it but it might
also be something which is dangerous
because they could just call the first
ten percent and this might be people
which are then may be reminded to cancel
that contract or something like that so
you should you should better have maybe
an intelligent decision behind it to
really do directly a target a promotion
or some individualized method to prevent
the churn and this would then be the way
from predictive too prescriptive
actually another thing which i just used
x example through the whole talk was
this demand forecast so that it was just
maybe a dis jeans or something on this
specific catalog for this item and for
this photo size and then you do the to a
prediction which would then be the green
dot and you compare it in the end with
your truths which would be the which
would be the the Red Cross afterwards
and you would if you would have
something like like a measure of the so
let's say the variance of your of your
prediction then you could see if if your
hole density distribution make sense and
you could say okay I want to be that
sure that I'm not overestimating or
underestimating and here again the
demand forecast is only something where
the customer would get the information
okay tomorrow the screens might be sold
ten times but then still the case is
this really useful or or not so if you
think for example on the supermarket
thing so there if you know tomorrow I
don't know this bottle of water
will be sold ten times this is something
which is not really useful but if you
would know you have to two other five
bottles so this would be something which
would be useful so that means you would
do kind of a replenishment after such
and such and demand forecast so and why
you would do it because you don't want
to have to to view or too many articles
or that in the end because if you have
to to view then you just lose revenue
you have high costs to to maybe buy new
stuff from a supplier and the customers
of course not happy if you have too much
then you have to cost to need to to
store other stuff and you waste just
just trust the goods they have to be
thrown away and this is also something
which we don't know so that means by
that you can just if you find the right
cost function and in the end then you
have you have a decision for the
customers where it's not necessary for
them to really find a solution out of
trust number so as a conclusion so what
the data saw what data scientists are so
there are quite a few different let's
say definitions of it so they can be
data hygienist so that means you have to
to keep the data clean over the whole
lifecycle your data Explorer you have to
find the data sets which are necessary
for your specific use case you need to
put it in a way that you can use it in
your model for this specific business
case you are an model developers which
would be one definition of data
scientists in its own that you're really
knowing machine learning statistics and
yarn and in the end you have to have I
have to be a business expert through
turn the models into results and into a
business case so and as last words so
real world data science really includes
operationalization so that means is hold
platform discussion with which we had so
this is really necessary that you are
not just building your our model and
then
afterwards you make a powerpoint
presentation and that's it so that means
the ultimate goal of it would be
automated decisions so that you really
build models which were where it's not
necessary for the customer to to think
about it anymore but you have everything
automatic pilot and that pizen is great
for data science actually so you have
you have tools for fast model
development and it's also suited for
productive use so and this is also why
we decided at some point to trust you
spies and throughout the whole process
actually yeah and that's basically
yeah thanks a lot physics for this nice
overview talk I think we have time for
one or two questions as one in the back
thank you you presented data scientists
like kind of a black box where you put
data in and you get a result out but I
think shouldn't it be more like you're
developing a question you want to answer
together with your em with a company and
then you just collect that data create
the models and stuff and use the domain
knowledge of the company to create
better features not only just extract
features that are there but combine them
with domain knowledge to get even more
insight and later on if you I don't know
have like a few hundreds or thousands
features you want to do some selection
of that as well and I kind of missed
that in there yeah so the question was
if it should be so it was presented like
a black box and it should be more like
that the custom understands what's going
on so basically add it's true so it
depends on the customer of course so of
course internally you know what's going
on and you have your your predictive
application which i have now here so
with this external factors and all these
things so of course you you have to have
the experts and the customer side
included so this is because you don't
know the data as good as as they do so
and this is always the case so you have
to be in contact with them and this is
also what i meant a bit with this with
this business development so you need to
have this expertise knowledge and then
you can include it so you should never
just the just user is as a as a black
box method without caring about the
specific use case so definitely not all
right so we're running out of time a bit
so maybe you can get in touch yeah just
the alternate oh okay fine thanks again
you
you